guys i think i have to leave the
republican party i think i have to
totally
just re-envision how i think about
things because i saw a tweet
from the actress rosanna arquette and
this was just wow
wow i'll just read it for you democrats
versus nazi party that's where we are
at in america oh it's just
i've never heard it put that way before
you know it just totally makes me think
about politics in a fresh new way that's
the kind of rhetoric
that's going to change our politics i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from one time
282 who says put your hands up if you
had to google pinko
and put your hands up if you're going to
start using that word from now on well
that's
a few people wrote into me just i guess
i used the word pinko in passing
yesterday
and they were unfamiliar with that pinko
is one of the great terms it's one of
the great terms for the libs or
you know like the commies but now the
libs are kind of like the commies and
that's why we call them pinkos
so i'm glad yes let's bring that back i
didn't know it ever went away
you know when you want to make sure that
things are ready for
the future things from the past are
ready for the future you've got to check
out
trust and will what a segway that was
baby
at trustanwill.com setting up an estate
plan is simple
convenient and secure for as little as
39
you can nominate guardians for your
children determine who gets your stuff
and plan for future medical care all
from the comfort of your home
and with live customer support seven
days a week trust in will.com team is
available to answer any questions you
have
while setting up your plan trust and
will is a trusted name in online estate
planning the category leader on
trustpilot and they've helped hundreds
of thousands of people protect their
families assets and legacies
i have had a will since i was 18 years
old 17 years old something like that
it's very important and now then i got
married you got to update it now i've
got cute little june gotta update it
again trust and will fabulous place to
do it i really recommend them
gain peace of mind that's what this is
all about at trustonwill.com
knowles don't don't leave problems for
your family go check it out
i get 10 off plus free shipping on your
customized legal documents don't wait go
right now this is
extremely important seriously do it do
it now when people die without a will
it's a big problem just do it peace of
mind ten percent off
plus free shipping at trustingwill.com
noles trustingwill.com
knowles liz cheney is gone no one really
cares about that it's fine it's over
it's
no big deal the only people who are
pretending to care and trying to make a
huge issue out of this
are the democrats who are turning liz
cheney into a martyr and they are using
liz cheney
as an opportunity to regurgitate the
stalest
deadest that that is the actual problem
in in our politics for anyone who wants
to make progress
joy behar calling liz cheney
joan of arc she is the joan of arc
standing up to the heretics at this
point
and so she's very lonely in that
position i do have faith though that she
is a tough cookie
and intends to persevere uh it is rather
refreshing to see
somebody stand up to the q anon party
uh who's not afraid to lose her job like
the rest of those cowards
who are shivering and quivering in the
corner that they may have to go back to
their old lives
but i have to say that i have not been a
republican
fan as you might have noticed over the
years on this show
i mean the big lie of the iraq war was
the republican party this is just
another big lie
that they're perpetuating on the
american people
this is just a stew of dead
stupid talking points this is a
veritable smoothie
of all the dumbest talking points that
you can throw into the blender and then
you put the top on you
that is joy behar's monologue here so
notice notice what she's doing
you hear the big lie which is this
phrase that democrats are using from
hitler they're borrowing it from hitler
in mein kampf
and they're using that to accuse the
republicans of being nazis even though
they don't realize
that in their analogy the way that
they're using the big lie actually
makes the democrats into the nazis and
the republicans into the jews but they
haven't read mineconf and they don't
know very much about history
so okay they're using that to talk about
the questions about the 2020 election
but but now joy behar is saying but but
the big lie that the republicans are
pushing there's
the big lie is also the iraq war you
know the big lie it's just one lie and
that's about the election
having problems but also but it's also
the iraq war in iraq where there was all
the republicans
even though uh hillary clinton voted for
it and i think
pretty sure joe biden voted for it too
but no it's the republicans
and okay so that's the first part
totally wrong there and then she
but the first part rather is like the
the earlier part in her monologue
is where she refers to liz cheney as
joan of arc
and she says that she's joan of arc
against the gop heretics
but what is that heretic against what
what is the belief is it against america
if if america is the the true wonderful
belief and the whole gop their heretics
then liz cheney i guess is still a
heretic because she's still a republican
that's that is her party affiliation
so i guess in her very confused metaphor
here
joy behar is saying that actually liz
cheney is the
joan of arc against the heretics of the
gop
who who have betrayed true conservatism
or the true republican party or
something like that
but joy behar doesn't know anything
about the republican party and if
if she really believes that
liz cheney is the good one or something
and that that the
the rest of the gop the conservative
types are heretics
then in in that metaphor joy behar would
have to become a republican albeit a
republican of the liz cheney variety but
she's not doing that
she doesn't believe anything that she's
saying or she doesn't even know what
what what the meaning is
that she is conveying she's just using
slogans the slogans can contradict one
another they can be internally
inconsistent they cannot convey meaning
it doesn't matter
her brain has been turned into a slogan
machine
and it's not just joy behar i i bring
this up because we're all susceptible to
this right now
this is always true in politics but
especially in the age of mass corporate
media
our thoughts are very often not our own
our look we all talk to people and we
get ideas from people and we bounce
ideas off of others and then we take
some good ideas i do it we all do it
but in the age of mass corporate media
these ideas are just pummeled into our
heads and they're all the same talking
points and it's day in and day out and
so we'll regurgitate them but we'll have
no idea what we're saying
i remember once right around when ronald
reagan died i was coming out of my
liberal phase
and my mother was very sad that ronald
reagan died and
and i didn't i didn't know you know i
just didn't know as much about reagan
and i said oh yeah but mom
you know everyone's everyone knows
reagan you know wasn't great
and she said why's that i said ah you
know like reaganomics
she goes hey michael what's reaganomics
i was like uh
uh i don't know i don't i just i've been
told
it was it was not even forget about
ronald reagan forget about what it means
on that particular issue
it was my first awakening
about the effects of the media
on our own language we can use it
without even knowing it
you want to talk about a real talking
point machine claire mccaskill who is
the former missouri senator who got
booted out by josh hawley
she is a queen of talking points and she
was she was spewing all the same
nonsense
also in this case about liz cheney but
mccaskill took it even one step further
down the rhetoric rabbit hole think how
far the republican party has fallen
that now not only do they accept
people committing insurrection and
sedition against our government
not only do they accept the president
united states committing a fraud a big
lie
on our democracy which we treasure
not only are they doing that they're
continuing
to sit silently as they oust a truth
teller
you know and i gotta tell you the truth
if one of these republicans has the
nerve
to talk about cancer culture with what
they're doing to liz cheney
i would use such an unladylike word
right now if i could
i mean ephem you know i mean what about
that they wanna they wanna lecture us
about dr
seuss and the cancelled culture and they
are canceling her
they are canceling liz cheney because
she has the audacity to tell the truth
shame on all of them and and
proving that we need a show on premium
cable where we can use that word because
it's so called for it
oh yeah we need a show we're so
subversive here
we're there's nothing more subversive
than saying the f word right
i think you can i think they're i think
like every show on premium cable does
that
right there's no the most subversive
thing you can do right now is not use
swear words
south park actually had a very funny
episode about this
decades ago back when when tv started
using all this
subversive vulgar language which but
which is now the norm i talk about this
actually at length in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which is available now for
pre-order you can get a signed first
petition copy by the way premiere
collectibles
but that the whole the whole setup is
ridiculous
she says oh yeah we oh we need a place
on the on cable where we can use those
naughty words yeah it's called cable you
can't
you so that's the first part
then there's the big lie and the threat
toward democracy all this stale
platitudinous nonsense
but then did you see did you see what
claire mccaskill said
within 10 seconds she said liz cheney is
a truth teller
and she's being punished for being a
truth teller and i've got to tell you
the truth
i've got to tell you the truth meaning i
wasn't telling you the truth before
ordinarily i don't tell you the truth
but now i've got to tell you the truth
this is so unusual for me but now i've
got to tell you the truth it's like the
people who say
look honestly as opposed to you know
dishonestly or
hey you know to be honest unlike what i
usually am which is dishonest
what meaning did claire mccaskill convey
if you did not know the context of
the partisan context of what these
people are generally getting at and you
just heard her say
the big lie is a threat to our democracy
which we cherish and the truth teller
was kicked out for the lie and the truth
and the
what are we talking about nowhere does
she talk about the big lie she doesn't
get into the details of the election
she doesn't get into the questions of
why people have maybe have some
lingering questions with the election
she doesn't get into what liz cheney
said or did
she doesn't get into what liz cheney
believes she doesn't get into what her
opponent said or did or believe
there's no specificity here it's just
the platitudinous
talking points the other big one i'm
hearing
with with regard to liz cheney is
country over party you ever hear that
one country over party
that might be the single most
ridiculously
silly slogan i've heard in my entire
life in politics and i grew up in the
co-exist bumper sticker era okay
there have been a lot of silly slogans
but country over party what does that
mean
people join political parties because
they think that will be good for their
country they join political parties to
advance a particular political vision
for their country
the idea that party is opposed to
country is just a
cheap insult but it doesn't mean
anything it's not true for anybody
and if you want progress such as it is
if anyone's really after progress in
politics
it is simply the case that regurgitating
these meaningless
vapid platitudes will do nothing by the
way conservatives have their own
conservatives do our you know
conservatives we'll we'll use this line
this is one of the most popular ones
democrats are the real racists
okay what does that mean well yeah sure
it
it is true that the democrats pursue
policies that are racist or racialist or
race-based or they
espouse hatred of people on the basis of
their race that's true
but democrats are the real racists
doesn't really mean anything because
what
racism is an offense against human
dignity it's a product of a fallen world
and we've all got it
the fallenness and therefore we've all
we all sin
i'm not saying we're all david duke or
anything like that but i'm saying we all
sin we all have problems we all have
difficulties of perception in this world
there are always questions of prejudice
and solving these things is not so easy
is slapping a bumper sticker on
something
so when we engage in that kind of talk
it's it's
it's not even that it's just so awful
and evil and terrible it's just it's a
waste of time
it does not do anything the left does it
way more than the right this but
we've got to watch it a little bit too
we got to work on ourselves if you want
to work on yourself you got to check out
echelon fitness echelon is the
affordable way to get the workout
equipment
the workout community and an
instructor's motivation right
in the comfort of your own home
echelon's fitness app provides you
thousands of live and on-demand classes
with great music from your favorite
artists just pick
your class climb the leaderboard cheer
each other on and give it your all
full range of affordable workout
equipment including stationary bikes
smart rowers
sleek fitness screens or the auto
folding treadmill they're all available
all connected
with the echelon experience they're
super super cool
these sorts of bikes can be ridiculously
expensive echelon will give you a great
great
deal i i really love these things right
now my listeners will get a special
podcast offer from echelon for a limited
time
start your 30-day risk free trial offer
with echelons
ex-3 that bike will be
just one dollar one dollar
for 30 days special risk-free offer for
30 days
with echelon's ex-3 bike for just one
dollar to start plus free shipping
only when you get this special offer is
by going to echelonfit.com
knowles e-c-h-e-l-o-n-f-i-t dot com
slash
echelon fit.com knowles there's this
great deal of importance on the the
quality of our thought on the rigor of
our logic and on the precision of our
language we've got to be very careful
about that
okay i just actually coincidentally just
wrote a book about this called
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which is available now for
pre-order by the way if you haven't
pre-ordered it yet
there it goes that bell was a little bit
late but you get the point
however i want to couch that i don't
want to seem just like i'm
you know 100
completely obsessed that everything's
got to be exactly precise and we've all
got to agree with each other on
everything and we can't ever
you know if you just sit and think about
language all day long you'll never do
anything else so i think we need to
train ourselves to be very precise
in all those things but we also have to
do stuff and in order to do stuff you
need coalitions and this is the other
side of that argument
this is what we're actually learning
from the whole liz cheney nonsense and
how the left is so thrilled with the
list chaining nonsense and most
republican voters aren't even aware of
it
we need to form political coalitions
there's a woman who just showed up
to a a meeting in lewden county virginia
and she it was a school board meeting
and she gave
a fiery denunciation of
critical race theory in the words of
martin luther king jr i have a dream
that my four little children will one
day live a nation where they will not be
judged by the color of their skin
but by the content of their character
now i have a dream that we will
implement love not hate
or supporting another jim crow's agenda
crt is not an honest dialogue is a
tactic that was used by hitler and the
klu klux klan
on slavery very many years ago to dumb
down my ancestors
so we could not think for ourselves crt
is racist
it is abusive it discriminates against
one's color let me educate you
an honest dialogue does not impress oh
press an honest dialogue does not
implement hatred or injustice
it's to communicate with deceiving
without deceiving people
today we don't need your agreement we
want action in the backbone
for what we ask for today to ban crt we
don't want your political advertisement
to divide our children or belittle them
think twice before you indoctrinate
such racist theories you cannot tell me
what is or is
not racist look at me i had to come down
here today to tell you to your face that
we are coming together and we are
strong this will not be the last greet
and meet
respectfully okay now
a lot of people are going to watch this
even conservatives even people who
oppose critical race theory
they're going to watch this or listen to
this and they're going to say oh well
i don't i don't agree with all of her
rhetoric oh well
i don't you know some of those
comparisons they're a little bit much
for me uh you know that this could have
been a little more articulated this
could have been stated differently
i agree as we've just been talking about
i agree it's very important to be
precise in our language
and it's very important to be aware when
of when people are not being precise and
when people are just using platitudes
and things like that
it is also important to be politically
effective
the main takeaway i get from this woman
is kick critical race theory out of
schools
i totally agree with that she's
absolutely right
we need to join with her we need to
welcome anybody
who will oppose critical race theory it
is poison in schools
it is terrible for our politics it is
based on a lie
it undermines our very faculties of
reason
you got to get rid of it so
well we can do two things at once you
often hear people say you can walk and
chew gum at the same time
we can improve our rhetoric we can be
aware
of the platitudes around us especially
from the left because those are the ones
being pumped in
from the schools from political race
theory actually from the big tech
from big corporate america from big
government from
big administrative state from everybody
from big hollywood
you you can be aware of that and you can
try to call people's attention to that
and you can also engage in political
coalitions
to fight these things that woman i would
love show me the next time she's talking
at a school board i want to be there i
want to be there to applaud her
because she's absolutely absolutely
right about what we need
to do speaking of lessons rand paul just
taught a very
lovely lesson to dr fauci dirk de ferci
only 10 more years you sheep put your
masks on only what did i say i said only
12 more years
no dr fauci you just said 10 more years
look i just it's only 15 more years of
the masks okay
that is the saiyans so dr senator rand
paul
just laid out a bit of a medical lesson
for
dr fauci dr falchi we don't know whether
the pandemic started in a lab in wuhan
or evolve naturally but we should want
to know
three million people have died from this
pandemic and that should cause us to
explore all possibilities
instead government authorities
self-interested in continuing
gain of function research say there's
nothing to see here
gain of function research as you know is
juicing up
naturally occurring animal viruses to
infect humans
to arrive at the truth the us government
should admit that the wuhan virology
institute
was experimenting to enhance the
coronavirus's ability to infect humans
juicing up superviruses is not new
scientists in the u.s have long known
how to mutate animal viruses to infect
humans
for years dr ralph barrick a virologist
in the u.s
has been collaborating with dr xi xengli
of the wuhan virology institute sharing
his discoveries about how to create
superviruses this gain of function
research has been funded
by the nih brutal so there's the setup
there the setup which is by the way
there were a lot of people
even among conservatives who early on in
the coronavirus said
this is totally naturally occurring this
has nothing to do with the chinese
government
there's no issue here with the public
health administration it's because of
the it's the
bat markets in wuhan and on this show
and on verdict with ted cruz we said
very early on
that the coincidence of the wuhan
virology institute being just
400 yards from where this virus was
allegedly discovered
that's a little too much for us i bet it
has something to do with the institute
and i bet that some american people are
going to be held accountable for or at
least going to be exposed for this
because as we reported on that show too
u.s money u.s taxpayer dollars were
going in part to fund the wuhan
institute of virology
which was studying coronaviruses and
bats people called conspiracy theorists
all sorts of things by the libs and by
even some self-styled conservatives
looks like we were right rand paul
laying this out in the senate
dr fauci he's he denies it but listen
this is the importance of rhetoric
listen to the way in which he denies it
dr
fauci do you still support funding of
the
nih funding of the lab in wuhan
senator paul with all due respect you
are entirely entirely
and completely incorrect that the nih
has not ever and does not now fund
gain of function research in the wuhan
institute do they find doctors we do not
fund you dr barracks gain of function
research
dr barrett does not doing gain to
function research
and if it is it's according to the
guidelines
and it is being conducted in north
carolina
i don't think it's turning up oh dr
fauci you know
you're a you're a clever tricky
politician
but thankfully rand paul is too and he's
calling you out on it
so dr foughty opens because dr paul
senator paul you are completely and
totally incorrect
about this very narrow thing that i'm
actually distorting your words on so
he's not
fauci is even though he says you're
completely and totally incorrect right
you get the sound bite
then he qualifies that he says about
this very particular thing and then you
think about the very particular thing
namely funding gain of function research
in wuhan
and you realize wait a second that's not
quite what rand paul was accusing you of
you're saying you're totally wrong about
that thing that you didn't actually say
well okay so
rand paul you're totally and completely
incorrect about the thing that you
didn't actually say the u.s
taxpayer dollars do not go toward gain
of function research
in wuhan but as rand paul asks he says
well
are you funding dr barrick this this one
particular doctor doing gain of function
research which he's then sharing with
wuhan
and fauci doesn't want to answer it so
he just keeps talking over paul
and then paul axe asks it again and then
fauci gives to me it's
this is the just the cherry on top of
this little rhetorical sunday he goes
dr barrick is not conducting gain of
function research
and if he is it's fine well you
declarative statement dr barrick is not
doing this kind of research
but if he is it's totally cool it's not
a problem what do you mean but if you
just you're making the statement that
he's not doing it
you can't then qualify that and say yeah
but if he is whatever don't who cares
where the mask sheep
his his response to paul
which is given such such fire with such
passion
is ultimately meaningless he doesn't
refute a single thing rand paul accuses
him of
but people will think that he did the
way that this is being portrayed in the
mainstream media
is as the dr fauci owns rand paul that's
how it's being played
and no one's going into this depth on it
no one's analyzing what dr fauci
actually said
they're just taking it they're just
taking the dead rhetoric for what it is
but rand paul really did expose
something here doesn't matter
oh you've got to wait to see the way cnn
covers it
cnn accusing rand paul
of of disrespecting medical science rand
paul a medical doctor
oh my gosh this craziness just makes you
want to crawl back into bed especially
when you've got bowling branch
sheets if you dream of comfortable
sheets at a price that won't keep you
up all night look no further than
bowling branch bowlin branch makes the
softest organic sheets on the market
they get better with every wash buttery
soft lightweight organic cotton
and a classic sateen weave for sheets
that get softer over time not too hot
not too cool the perfect year-round
sheets for most sleepers best of all
bowling branch gives you a fair price
plus a 30-day risk-free trial with free
shipping
and returns i first got bowling brand
sheets when they advertised years ago
and i had a queen-sized bed
we love them we love them we love them
then we get a bigger bed uh-oh we don't
have the bowling brand sheets what am i
going to do
shockingly and you know what a cheap
skate i am i'm going to buy more bowling
brand sheets
then mullenbranch sends us another pair
truly my wife has never been happier
with any advertising experience
experience the best sheets that you've
ever felt at bowlingbranch.com
get 15 off your first set of sheets when
you use promo code michael at checkout
fifteen percent off at bowling branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code michael also
make sure you check out ben shapiro's
show ben is gonna be talking about
bite inflation uh ben never can resist a
good pun
and some bad puns too ben has never met
a pun he didn't lie go
so it's very important topic though so
go check that out about bidenflation and
also be on the lookout for ben's
new book the authoritarian moment this
is the second best
book that's coming out in the next two
months if you want to preserve
the american way of life and protect the
ones you love from mob rule
go check out that book today it's
available for pre-order it's actually
really terrific to pre-order ben's book
after you pre-order my book it's real
it goes very well in the cart when you
first you click uh
speechless controlling words controlling
minds and then only after that
is it great to pre-order uh the
authoritarian moment go do it
you can pre-order it at amazon barnes
noble or any other major bookseller
we'll be right back with a lot more
rand paul rips dr fauci at the senate
rand paul
brings names brings evidence
uh and brings serious questions dr fauci
can't refute any of them the best he can
muster
is to answer questions that rand paul
didn't ask
and to ignore the questions that he
actually did ask how is this being
covered in the mainstream media why
anderson cooper of cnn is accusing
or and people on his program are
accusing dr
rand paul of disrespecting medical
science
he's an ophthalmologist you would think
that he would uh
be you know have more respect at least
for medical science
dr fauci um he later told
uh cnn's dr sanji gupta do you think
senators might be playing to the cameras
it's certainly you know that could
certainly be it the idea that
fauci is somehow a villain to trump
allied politicians
what does one even say to that idea
this is look obviously the substance of
what he's saying is
is very silly the idea that anderson
cooper
this tv host vanderbilt is somehow the
great defender
of medical science against rand paul
who's disrespecting medical science
even though he's a medical doctor that's
very silly stuff
but i want to focus in on that little
rhetorical trick at the end
did you hear what he said there he says
it's just crazy it's just so ridiculous
that
dr fauci would become the villain to
these trump
allied politicians so first of all in
the example he's giving here rand paul
who's probably
the the greatest foe that dr fauci has
in politics rand paul is a scientist
he's a medical doctor so
it's not scientist fauci versus
politician rand paul
it's scientists versus science they're
both scientists but moreover
they're both politicians dr fauci is a
politician
dr fauci gets his paycheck from the
government dr faucio reports to
presidents
he's reported to presidents going back
to ronald reagan
dr fauci is one of the most seasoned
politicians in
the country and he has more political
power than virtually anybody in the
country
presidents come and go dr fauci remains
this is the campbell can you believe the
politician versus the scientist no
it's scientist versus scientist and
politician versus politician
public health is about applying a
supposedly scientific lens to politics
and giving supposed scientists a lot of
political power
if you wanted to have a real substantive
discussion about this
you would not do what anderson cooper is
doing you would not do what
i don't any of these people on
television are doing
any of these libs pinkos to use a phrase
that some of the audience likes
you would say okay you've got you've got
two scientist politicians here
and you've got two you've got a
scientific disagreement first of all
and frankly i don't even know i don't
want to accuse fauci of bad motives
or of hiding the ball even though he has
clearly misled and lied to people so
maybe i can accuse him of that
but fauci maybe fauci actually
understands that there's a very good
chance that the wuhan institute was
somehow involved here but fauci just
doesn't want to admit that because of
the political considerations but let's
just say
best case scenario you've got a
scientific disagreement
and you've got a political disagreement
between the u.s senator
and the egghead technocrat
now in the constitutional order
it seems to me preferable for the
senator to win
in that situation as the senator is
accountable in some way to the people
in our constitutional system and the
egghead technocrat is not you can't you
can't kick him out
you can't fire fauci the guy is going to
be there for our grandchildren
are going to be answering to dr fauci
because i don't know what kind of deal
that guy made but
he doesn't you know dr fauci is at least
going to live until 250. i think we all
know that at this point
he still won't be able to throw a
baseball but he's gonna he's gonna be
around a long time okay
that would be the honest discussion
where do we disagree on the science and
where do we disagree on the politics and
how do those two things relate because
they obviously do
but we can't have that discussion
because of all this stupid dead rhetoric
the one
one nice thing i'll say about someone on
cnn about don lemon of all people
is that don lemon cracked out and he
actually has done this in the past
he has cracked out of the dead rhetoric
years ago he used to agree with bill
o'reilly on things right that was that's
certainly breaking the mold on cnn
but even when he's offering liberal
talking points
he very often comes at it from an
oblique angle i mean do you remember
some
some years ago uh don lemon would talk
about aliens and he'd talk
talk about weird things spat off on
religion and he doesn't know anything
about it but at least it was
different at least you could tell he
wasn't just regurgitating the same
nonsense that many of his colleagues do
he did this recently on the vaccines
he was doing his little hand off the
tweedledee tweedledum thing
you know to chris cuomo and they were
talking about mother's day
and don lemon made a fairly interesting
point
i'm kind of jealous that you got to
spend it with your mom because i'd love
to spend it with my mom but my mom
won't leave she won't i keep saying mom
she has to fly though
she is fully vaccinated chris and if
you're going to say
during the entire pandemic and i'm
talking to you mom
and i'm talking to you my other friend i
won't say her name because you'll get
mad at me
if you're going to say i believe in the
science and the scientists
then now on this side of the pandemic
then you must believe in the science and
scientists as well
i agree saying to you if you're fully
vaccinated you don't have to wear a mask
outside
if you want to travel you can wear a
mask follow the protocols
but it is 99.99 or whatever percent
chances that you won't get the covid
you won't get coveted then you should
trust in that science as well and get
back to your life my mom
is is a woman of a certain age i don't
know how much time any of us has
i could walk out here and get hit by a
bus i'm i want to live my life
i want to see my loved ones so can we
get back to some semblance
of normalcy preach preach don
man that was great i totally agree
i i totally agree with what he said in
part because
he couched a lot of it hypothetically so
he said if you always believe the
scientists and if you
think it's important to wear the mask so
obviously i i don't i don't care what dr
fauci says i don't think he has any
credibility i don't wear the masks
almost ever unless people absolutely
force me to like for instance to get on
an airplane
and then i have to make a calculation is
it worth even traveling to this place to
wear this stupid mask
but sure i don't you know some of the
hypothetical parts i don't
get into but the argument he's making
here is completely right
even if you've gone along with all this
craziness all the
fouchy whatever fouchy says this minute
that's the gospel truth
well now we are being told by the
egghead uh health professionals
you don't need to wear a mask outside
you can see your family if you've been
vaccinated that's the point of a vaccine
you can do this you can do that
so the people who have done all those
things have to be consistent and he says
look
who knows how long we have to live a lot
of us have put off seeing our
grandparents
a lot of us have put off seeing our
parents and
who knows as he says you go walk out and
get hit by a bus tomorrow
and certainly the chances of something
happening increase with age and
with deteriorating health so go out and
live you have to live your life i'm
shocked this made it through on cnn
that only make it through on the handoff
now
okay i can't i'm saying too many nice
things about don lemon saying too many
nice things about cnn
so let's get back into their really
stupid rhetoric again
fareed zakaria goes actually goes on don
lemon's show
and fareed zechariah goes into the
issue of israel and the violence
breaking out and palestine
and peace in the middle east and his the
problem with his argument here
is is not even so much the specifics of
how this applies right now
people could have an honest disagreement
about what's going on right now it's
that he is retreating
to the same dumb platitudes
that have failed for decades bibi
netanyahu meanwhile was trying to do
uh things that would make it as
impossible
for there ever to be a palestinian state
as as he could do
so he makes peace with some moderate
gulf
states with the help of the united
states uh and he had been
essentially ruling out any possibility
of any
any deal with the palestinians so after
a while
i think what happened is there was a
certain amount of frustration
that you know these events then get
triggered by something or the other
but the reality is that israel had
almost forgotten
that they had this palestinian problem
on their hands
and it has now exploded but ultimately
this thing is only going to be
solved if israel decides that it wants
to as a
as a matter of morality it does it wants
to give rights to palestinians
that it does not believe that it can be
a jewish democratic state
and have these four million people
living essentially in
uh conditions where they have no
political rights in israel
and you know has has control over them
okay
do you see the problem with what he's
just said so he
he opens up with a brief history of the
past few years
which has overseen relative peace
in israel and relative peace in the
middle east
that is this was the the trump strategy
for years and years and decades and
decades we were told by the foreign
policy establishment
that you would not see peace in the
middle east
unless and you would not see
normalization of states with israel
unless you first deal with the
palestinian issue
and the palestinian issue is this group
of arabs that are kind of in a no man's
land where
none of the arab states want them and
they want to destroy israel and they
elect hamas a terrorist organization but
israel doesn't just totally wipe them
out and so
there's just this conflict right if you
don't deal with the palestinian problem
you're never going to get
peace with arab nations and and israel
and then trump said
you know that's that just sounds like bs
so you know what i'm going to do i'm
going to do the exact opposite
john kerry goes out and says it is a
fact it is a reality you will never
have a separate peace in the middle east
if you don't deal with the palestinian
issue trump says now forget that i'm
just gonna we're just gonna deal with
the actual arab nation states
and israel and what does trump do he
doubles the number of
arab states that have normalized
relations with israel
doubles them he got two in a month two
in a month
major peace treaties the abraham accords
shocking upended
all of the foreign policy establishment
made them look like a bunch of idiots
then what happens biden becomes
president
and just retreats back to the exact same
old
issue he starts sucking up to iran again
starts sucking up to the palestinian
arabs again
pulls a little bit of support from
israel says we've got to solve the
palestinian problem what happens
violence breaks up
and fareed zakori at least ign he says
look the
the israelis during the trump
administration they just kind of forgot
the palestinian arabs exist
they didn't forget they just ignored
them that was the strategy ignore this
problem ignore hamas ignore that was the
trump strategy just ignore them
don't try to deal with them just deal
with the other countries
and then you're going to get peace so
yes you know and that was good it led to
some peace and it led to
but then what happened what does fareed
say he says and that is why we now need
to go back to the palestinian
he ignores all the stuff he just said
all of the actual interesting specific
stuff that's going on right now and he
just retreats back to the old
dead platitudes just a stale talking
point
often these slogans are not just wrong
they're
actually the opposite of true a real
great example of this is in the current
prosecution
of that looney tune who shot up the
asian massage parlor do you remember
this is a couple months ago
a sex addict walks into a asian massage
parlor and just starts
shooting people presumably there was
more than massages going on in the
in the massage parlor now this was not
only an asian massage parlor there were
people who were non-asian as well
on tuesday this guy gets uh indicted
of killing eight people okay and not
only is he
being brought up on the murder charges
which is obviously right not only are
they seeking the death penalty which
they obviously should
but he's also being brought up on hate
crime charges
hate crime what's a hate crime it's
opposed to a love crime i guess
it's opposed to an indifference crime
it's a hate crime it's kind of a silly
identity politics category that
increases punishments based on perceived
motives of the killers
six of the eight people who were shot
were of asian descent
and the shooter here is white so he's
being brought up on a hate crime because
he must hate asian
people right but there's no evidence
that he hates asian people
he says and all the people around him
say and all the investigators are saying
that the motive was not race it was
actually sex it was that this guy
has a sex addiction and that he felt
that there was a temptation
from the asian massage parlors and so he
one day goes in and blows
blows them to smithereens
that's doesn't change the nature of the
crime whether he hated them for their
race or he hated them because he's got a
sex problem
doesn't change the the effect of the
crime
but and i don't think that the
punishment should be any different but
furthermore they're now adding this on
because they're because a lot of them
were asian and because he's white
they're saying it has to be racist
it's not racist that you don't learn
anything about the crime
you don't learn anything about the
actual situation you don't deter crime
you don't prevent anything
by pretending that every bad thing in
the world is motivated by racism
this is from the fulton county district
attorney fannie willis
who says the hate crime charges are
based on the actual or perceived race
national origin sex and gender of the
four women killed
the notice says only four women so not
even six okay
and then this d.a goes on and says
this will send a message that everyone
within this community is valued
but that's not the message it sends it
actually sends the opposite message
it sends the message that some people
are valued more than others if this guy
had gone in
and killed a bunch of white
masseuses you know in this kind of dodgy
massage parlor
he would face less of a of a charge
but because they're asian he faces a
greater charge the message that sends is
that asians are valued more than white
women
but that obvi that shouldn't be the
message sent at all and regardless of
whether or not that should be the
message sent
it's obviously not what's being sent it
is the opposite
of what this stale rhetoric is pushing
speaking of sex edition not a dish
addiction
we're you know just talking about the
the masseuse shooting issue
there is a very famous guy who is
admitting
to another kind of sex addiction porn
addiction
terry crews is opening up about his porn
addiction and how it almost
destroyed his marriage it was like wait
a minute like
i actually just need to be a better
person for myself
and and he basically said whether i
can't promise you whether your wife
was ever going to come back to you you
may have lost her forever
but you still need to get better for
yourself
this is crazy you're right because this
is another thing
success is the warmest place to hide i
had so many people that were telling me
i was great
that it was no problem that you're doing
this and you know what hollywood didn't
care
it still doesn't care if you lose your
family it happens every day they're like
hey man but now you can put you in three
movies
and i wanted to add that this addiction
preceded the marriage
so fame just made it worse and it's
really true that
that power that success amplifies what's
already going on inside you
and that is why i couldn't help him and
i'm thankful and i'm lucky
that he made the choice to do that this
porn addiction thing is a big problem i
cannot tell you
how many letters i get into the mailbag
and people sending in tweets and things
like that
who are young men who are asking about
porn addiction who are in despair
because they got hooked on porn from
when they were eight years old or
something
i mean i think that the average age that
boys are exposed to porn is like
10 or 11. and because it was when they
were so young it totally warped their
minds and they got stuck and it screws
up their relationship and it screws up
their sense of self-worth and screws up
the sense of the world
and this issue is one that is not really
talked about
and when it is talked about it's talked
about with flippancy
and glibness and the stale rhetoric of
the left and the right for that matter
on the right which you hear from the
kind of
basic boomer libertarian conservative
rhetoric is yeah come on you can't ban
porn it's free speech
come on you don't want to ban porn first
first of all you hear it from the right
wingers who they just really want to be
cool
you know like i'm not an i'm not i'm not
a usual kind of right winger i'm a cool
right winger it's like the mother and
mean girls you know i'm not a regular
mom i'm a cool
i'm a cool conservative you know yeah i
like porn or whatever and so you you
hear that kind of
silliness which there's nothing
conservative about porn okay but also
porn has not protected free speech it's
just not it never has been
and it probably it may very well be but
only because people are conflating
liberty and licentiousness
obscenity has never been protected by
law okay going back to the
earliest days of our of our country
actually even before the country was
officially founded you know in
the late 18th century going back to
governor bradford okay going back to the
mayflower and plymouth colony
there was a guy from a nearby colony who
wrote what what governor bradford
considered to be sort of
lecherous sonnets you know little little
poems that he felt were a little too
titillating for puritanical austerity
and governor bradford very nearly
executed him for that
okay and ultimately he said ah it'll be
kind of bad for the diplomatic issues
here
so instead governor bradford in his
great mercy marooned him on an island
until a ship from england could take him
back
and get him out of the mother country
okay that tradition goes back very far
in america
and in the early days we've had
protections against obscenity and we
were still enforcing them as recently as
2009
2009 at the tail end of the bush
administration
there was a pornographer who was sent to
prison for obscenity charges
not even it's not even like it was child
porn or it was this it was just
four obscene stuff we have lots of
limitations on this
we always have until recently when
conservatives putative conservatives
bought the liberal stupid rhetoric
about how there's nothing more american
and nothing more protected by the first
amendment
than looking at ladies jiggle on the
internet or weirder stuff you know
there's
basically a porn for everything right
that's the expression goes if you can
think it there's a porn for it that
stuff
we've got to take that seriously so you
got to ditch this stupid right-wing
rhetoric on it and you got to
ditch the stupid left-wing rhetoric on
it this is somehow good for you i mean
the left has been pushing the
sexualization of children for decades
and decades and decades
it goes back at least to one of these
kooky left theorists
wilhelm reich who was writing a century
ago almost a century ago
and and then you see the same nonsense
espoused by bernie sanders himself
very prominent left winger almost got
the democratic nomination for president
he's been a senator for forever
and he would write essays in the 60s in
the vermont freeman
about how we need to sexualize children
and how that's good for them
now we we need to normalize these sorts
of things you can read about that by the
way in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now
for pre-order the left has been pushing
that we got to ditch that kind of crazy
writer and by the way you want to talk
about stale rhetoric
the left always says that young men
toxic young men they need to talk about
their feelings and their problems
well okay the ones who are writing into
my show talking about this
very real issue they're talking about
their feelings and their problems and
what happens
they get made fun of they get called in
cells they get called losers they get
called basement dwellers by
by the very libs who are saying that the
young men need to talk about their
feelings
but we are not we are not allowed
to to talk about that
because of this it's it's not even
because we don't understand that there
is an issue i think people do sense that
there's an issue on the left and the
right
but we're just locked in this prism of
stupid stupid
slogans and it's it's being enforced by
the liberal establishment there is some
good news though on this messaging front
so the the uh baltimore state attorney
marilyn mosby one of the most radical
loons out there in in office today
she filed a complaint with the fcc the
federal communications commission
accusing a fox news affiliate of
endangering the lives of mosby
and her family with racist news coverage
that because fox the loca it's not even
fox the cable channel it's fox the local
affiliate
because they weren't spouting the
left-wing line that that's racist
and that endangers her family and the
fcc's got to kick them off so fcc
commissioner brendan carr had a great
response he said
the state attorney's office led by
democrat marilyn mosby
has launched a chilling and direct
attack on free speech and journalistic
freedom
it is particularly troubling that a
public official would work to silence
reporters that are investigating her
work
at a time when federal prosecutors have
already opened a criminal investigation
to her
activities the fcc should make clear
that it will not operate
as the dnc's speech police good i'm very
glad that at least the government is not
totally getting involved here
in enforcing the left's stale
crazy rhetoric they're involved to some
degree but not not at the level of the
fcc that's what we're gonna have to
crack we have to pay
clear attention to language here folks
which of course is the sort of thing
that you can read about in my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now for
pre-order
is that uh-oh what's going on that was
that was one two minute plug
oh no i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show i'll see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show president biden's
policies blow up
prices panic buying hits the southeast
as the gas runs out and liz cheney's
firefight with the gop is everything the
media could hope for that's today on the
ben shapiro show give it a listen